Soy Rich Baraniuk.
Y me gustaría hablar un poco hoy sobre algunas ideas
que creo tienen enorme resonancia
con todas las cosas que se han hablado en los últimos dos días.
De hecho, tantos puntos diferentes de resonancia
que va a ser difícil hablar de todos ellos, pero haré mi mejor esfuerzo.
¿Alguien recuerda estos?
(Risas)
Bien, estos son discos LP y han sido sustituidos.
Han sido barridos en las dos últimas décadas
por estos tipos de tecnologías de digitalización que aplanan el mundo.
Y creo que esto se vió mucho mejor
cuando Thomas estaba tocando música mientras entrábamos al auditorio hoy.
Lo que ha sucedido en el mundo de la música es que hay una cultura
o un ecosistema que ha sido creado
que, si toman unas palabras de Apple,
es el slogan: creamos, copiamos, mezclamos y quemamos.
Lo que quiero decir con esto es que cualquier persona en el mundo es libre
y tiene permitido crear nueva música e ideas musicales.
Cualquier persona en el mundo puede copiar ideas musicales,
usarlas de formas innovadoras.
Cualquier persona puede mezclarlas en diferentes maneras,
señalar conexiones entre ideas musicales
y la gente puede quemar o crear productos finales y continuar el ciclo.
Y lo que eso ha hecho es crear, como dije,
una vibrante comunidad que es muy inclusiva
con personas trabajando continuamente para conectar ideas musicales,
innovar sobre ellas y mantener las cosas constantemente al día.
El tema que es un éxito hoy no es el mismo tema que fue un éxito el año anterior, ok.
Pero, no estoy aquí para hablar de música.
Estoy aquí para hablar de libros.
En particular, los libros de texto y el tipo de materiales educativos
que usamos todos los días en la escuela.
¿Alguien aquí ha ido a la escuela?
(Risas)
Ok, ¿alguien ha notado que hay una crisis en nuestras escuelas,
alrededor del mundo?
Espero que sí, ok, no voy a gastar demasiado tiempo en eso,
pero sobre lo que quiero hablar es sobre algunas de las desconexiones
que aparecen cuando un autor publica un libro
que de hecho, el proceso de publicación --
sólo por el hecho de que es complicado,
es pesado, los libros son caros --
crea una especie de muro entre los autores de los libros
y los usuarios finales de los libros,
sean profesores, estudiantes o lectores en general.
Y esto es aún más cierto si usted habla un idioma
diferente de una de las principales lenguas del mundo, especialmente inglés.
Y voy a llamar a estas personas por debajo de la barrera "excluidos",
porque están realmente excluidos del proceso
de ser capaces de compartir sus conocimientos con el mundo.
Así que quiero hablar hoy de tratar de tomar estas ideas,
bien, que hemos visto en la cultura musical
y tratar de traerlas para reinventar la forma
en la que pensamos sobre escribir libros, usarlos y enseñar con ellos, ¿ok?
Entonces, eso es de lo que me gustaría hablar
y realmente, ¿cómo llegamos desde donde estamos ahora a donde tenemos que ir?
Así, la primera cosa que me gustaría que hicieran es un pequeño experimento mental.
Imaginen tomar todos los libros del mundo.
Ok, todo el mundo imagine libros
e imaginen arrancar sus hojas,
liberar estas páginas, e imaginen digitalizarlas, bien,
y después, almacenarlas en un repositorio vasto, interconectado y global.
Piensen en ello como un iTunes masivo, para contenido del tipo de libros.
Y luego tomen ese material e imaginen volverlo abierto,
para que la gente pueda modificarlo, jugar con él, mejorarlo.
Imaginen volverlo gratuito, de modo que cualquier persona en el mundo pueda tener acceso
a todo este conocimiento, e imaginen usar tecnología de la información
de modo que usted puede actualizar este contenido, mejorarlo, jugar con él,
en una escala de tiempo que es más del orden de segundos que de años,
Ok, en lugar de las ediciones que salen cada dos años,
de un libro, imaginen esas ediciones saliendo cada 25 segundos.
Entonces, imaginen que podemos hacer eso
e imaginen que ponemos a gente en esto.
Para que pudiéramos construir verdaderamente un ecosistema no sólo con los autores,
sino con todas las personas que podrían ser o quieren ser autores
en todos los diferentes idiomas del mundo,
y creo que si pudieran hacer esto, sería llamado, bueno,
voy a referirme a ello como un ecosistema del conocimiento.
Así que, realmente, este es el sueño
y, en cierto sentido, lo que puede pensar de él
es que estamos tratando de permitir que cualquier persona en el mundo,
-- y me refiero a cualquier persona en el mundo --
sea su propio DJ educativo,
creando materiales educativos, compartiéndolos con el mundo,
innovando constantemente sobre ellos. Entonces, este es el sueño.
De hecho, este sueño en realidad está siendo realizado.
En los últimos seis años y medio,
hemos estado trabajando realmente duro en la Universidad de Rice
en un proyecto llamado Connexions,
y lo que me gustaría hacer durante el resto de la charla
es contarles un poco sobre lo que las personas están haciendo
con Connexions, en el que pueden pensar como en un contrapunto
a la charla de ayer de Nicholas Negroponte,
donde ellos están trabajando en el hardware
de llevar la educación a todo el mundo.
Nosotros estamos trabajando en la herramientas de código abierto y el contenido, ¿de acuerdo?
Entonces, eso es para ponerlo en perspectiva.
Entonces crear... ¿qué es lo que son algunas de las personas que están usando este tipo de herramientas?
Bueno, lo primero es que
hay una comunidad de profesores de ingeniería, de Cambridge a Kioto,
que están desarrollando contenido sobre ingeniería eléctrica
para desarrollar lo que se puede pensar como un super libro de texto masivo,
que cubre toda el área de la ingeniería eléctrica
y no sólo eso, puede ser personalizado
para su uso en cada una de sus propias instituciones.
Personas como Kitty Jones, una "excluida",
profesora privada de música y madre de Champagne, Illinois,
que quería compartir su fantástico contenido musical con el mundo,
sobre cómo enseñar a los niños a tocar música.
Su material es utilizado ahora más de 600.000 veces por mes.
Un uso tremendo, tremendo.
De hecho, mucho de este uso proviene de Estados Unidos, a través de escuelas de primaria y secundaria
porque cualquier persona que está involucrada en un recorte escolar,
lo primero que corta es el currículo de música
y así lo que esto indica, precisamente, es la tremenda sed
por este tipo de contenido gratuito, abierto.
Muchos profesores están utilizando este material. Bien, ¿qué hay acerca de la copia?
¿Qué pasa con la copia, la reutilización?
Un equipo de voluntarios de la Universidad de Texas-El Paso,
estudiantes graduados de ingeniería traduciendo las ideas de este super libro de texto
y en una semana, más o menos, volvieron a este uno de nuestros materiales más populares,
con uso generalizado en toda América Latina y, en particular, en México,
debido a la naturaleza abierta y extensible de esto.
Personas, voluntarios, e incluso empresas
están traduciendo materiales a idiomas asiáticos
como el chino, japonés y tailandés,
para difundir el conocimiento aún más.
Bien, ¿qué pasa con la gente que está mezclando? ¿Qué significa mezclar?
Mezclar significa construir cursos personalizados,
significa construir libros personalizados.
Empresas como National Instruments,
están incluyendo simulaciones interactivas muy poderosas en los materiales,
de manera que podamos ir mucho más allá del libro de texto normal
a una experiencia en donde usted puede en realidad interactuar y jugar con
todos los materiales didácticos y cosas y,
de hecho, aprender a medida que hace.
Hemos estado trabajando con Profesores sin Fronteras (TWB)
que están muy interesados en mezclar nuestros materiales.
Ellos van a usar Connexions como plataforma
para desarrollar y entregar materiales didácticos
para enseñar a los profesores cómo enseñar
en 84 países alrededor del mundo.
TWB se encuentra actualmente en Iraq entrenando 20.000 profesores con el apoyo de USAID
y para ellos, esta idea de ser capaz de remezclar
y personalizar al contexto local es extraordinariamente importante,
porque tan sólo suministrar contenido gratuito a las personas
ha sido asimilado por personas en el mundo en vías de desarrollo
como una especie de imperialismo cultural,
así que si no se empodera a las personas
con la habilidad de re-contextualizar el material,
traducirlo a su propio idioma y apropiarse de él,
no está bien.
Otras organizaciones con las que hemos venido trabajando, UC Merced,
la gente sabe acerca de UC Merced.
Se trata de una nueva universidad en California, en el valle central,
que trabaja muy de cerca con universidades comunitarias.
Están desarrollando una gran parte de su plan de estudios de ciencias e ingeniería
para difundir ampliamente en todo el mundo en nuestro sistema
y también están tratando de desarrollar todas sus herramientas de software, completamente, de código abierto.
Hemos estado trabajando con AMD, que tiene un proyecto llamado 50 por 15,
que está tratando de llevar conectividad a Internet
al 50 por ciento de la población del mundo en 2015.
Vamos a proveerles contenido
en toda una gama de diferentes idiomas,
y también hemos estado trabajando con una serie de otras organizaciones.
En particular, un puñado de los proyectos
que son financiados por la Fundación Hewlett,
que han tenido un verdadero papel de liderazgo en esta área de contenido abierto.
Ok, quemar, creo que esto es muy interesante.
Quemar es la idea de tratar de crear la instanciación física de uno de estos cursos
y creo que muchos de ustedes recibieron,
creo que todos ustedes recibieron uno de estos libros de música en su maleta de regalos.
Un regalo para ti.
Sólo para decirles rápidamente sobre él, se trata de un libro de texto de ingeniería.
Se trata de 300 páginas de largo, de tapa dura.
Esto cuesta, ¿alguien lo puede adivinar?
¿Cuánto costaría en una librería?
Público: 65 dólares.
Richard Baraniuk: Esto le cuesta 22 dólares al estudiante.
¿Por qué cuesta 22 dólares?
Porque es publicado según demanda
y es desarrollado a partir de este repositorio de materiales abiertos.
Si este libro fuera publicado por un editor normal,
costaría al menos 122 dólares.
Entonces lo que estamos viendo es el movimiento de este 'quemado'
o proceso de publicación, de las revisiones periódicas de un libro con un único autor,
hacia materiales de autoría de la comunidad
que son modulares, que se adaptan a cada clase particular
y que son publicados según demanda a muy bajo costo,
ya sea a través de Amazon
o publicados directamente a través de una imprenta por demanda, como Coop.
Y creo que esta es un área extraordinariamente interesante
porque hay un enorme área bajo esta larga cola de publicación.
No estamos hablando del extremo de Harry Potter, justo al lado izquierdo.
Estamos hablando de libros de ecuaciones diferenciales parciales hipergeométricas.
Libros que podrían vender 100 ejemplares por año, 1000 ejemplares por año.
Hay un ingreso muy sostenible,
bajo esta larga cola para mantener proyectos abiertos como el nuestro,
pero también para sostener esta nueva aparición de editores por demanda,
como Coop que produjo estos dos libros.
Y creo que una de las cosas que ustedes deberían llevarse de esta charla,
es que hay un inminente recorte en el intermediario.
Desintermediación. Va a ocurrir en la industria editorial
y va a alcanzar un crescendo en los próximos años,
y creo que es realmente para nuestro beneficio, y para beneficio del mundo.
Bien, ¿cuáles son los facilitadores?
¿Qué está haciendo que todo esto suceda, en realidad?
Hay toneladas de tecnología,
y la única pieza de tecnología sobre la que realmente quiero hablar es XML.
¿Cuántas personas saben acerca de XML?
Genial, entonces es el futuro de la web.
Es la representación semántica del comentario, el contenido,
y lo que realmente pueden pensar de XML en este caso,
es que es el empaque que estamos poniendo en torno a estas páginas.
¿Recuerdan que tomamos el libro, y arrancamos sus páginas?
Bueno, lo que XML va a hacer es que va a ser básicamente --
va a convertir esas páginas en bloques de Lego.
XML son los salientes sobre el Lego, que permiten encajarlo con otros,
y que nos permite combinar el contenido en infinidad de formas diferentes
y nos proporciona un marco para compartir contenido.
Por lo tanto, les permite tomar este ecosistema,
en su estado primordial, de todos estos contenidos,
todas las páginas que arrancaron de los libros
y crear máquinas de aprendizaje altamente sofisticadas, ¿bien?
Libros, cursos, paquetes de cursos.
Les da la capacidad de personalizar la experiencia de aprendizaje
a cada estudiante particular,
de manera que cada estudiante puede tener un libro o un curso
personalizado para su estilo de aprendizaje, su contexto,
su lenguaje y las cosas que les interesan.
Les permite reutilizar los mismos materiales en múltiples formas diferentes,
y sorprendentes nuevas maneras.
Les permite interconectar ideas
indicando cómo los campos se relacionan entre sí,
y yo sólo les contaré mi historia personal.
Esto se nos ocurrió hace seis años y medio
porque yo enseño cosas como las que están en la caja roja.
Y mi trabajo diario, como dice Chris, soy un profesor de ingeniería eléctrica.
Doy clases de procesamiento de señales
y mi reto era demostrar que esta matemática --
wow, cerca de la mitad de ustedes ya se han dormido con sólo mirar a la ecuación --
(Risas)
que esta matemática aparentemente seca es en realidad el centro
de esta web tremendamente poderosa que enlaza tecnología --
que vincula aplicaciones estupendas como sintetizadores de música
a enormes oportunidades económicas,
pero regidas también por la propiedad intelectual.
Y de lo que me di cuenta es de que no había manera que yo,
como ingeniero, pudiera escribir este libro que conseguiría todo esto.
Necesitábamos una comunidad para hacerlo
y necesitábamos nuevas herramientas para ser capaces de interconectar estas ideas,
y creo que realmente, en cierto sentido, lo que estamos tratando de hacer
es de hacer realidad el sueño de Minsky,
donde se pueden imaginar todos los libros en una biblioteca
empezando a hablar unos con otros,
y aquellos de ustedes que son profesores,
quienes enseñan, saben esto.
Es acerca de las interconexiones entre las ideas de lo que se trata la enseñanza realmente.
Ok, de vuelta a las matemáticas, imaginen, esto es posible.
Que cada ecuación en la que se hace clic en uno de sus nuevos e-textos
es algo que van a poder explorar y con lo que van a poder experimentar.
Así que imaginen el libro de texto de álgebra de su hijo, en el séptimo grado.
Puede hacer clic en cada ecuación
y obtener una pequeña herramienta para poder experimentar con ella,
experimentar con ella, comprenderla,
porque realmente no entendemos hasta que hacemos.
El mismo tipo de lenguaje de marcado, como MathML, para la química.
Imaginen libros de texto de química que en realidad comprendan
la estructura de cómo se forman las moléculas.
Imaginen música en XML
que en realidad les permite profundizar en la estructura semántica de la música,
jugar con ella, comprenderla.
No es sorprendente que todo el mundo esté entrando en esto, ¿verdad?
Incluso los tres reyes magos.
(Risas)
Ok, el segundo gran facilitador, y aquí es donde dije una gran mentira,
el segundo gran facilitador es la propiedad intelectual,
porque en realidad me paré aquí
y hablé mucho acerca de cómo es de fabulosa la cultura de la música.
Podemos compartir y copiar, mezclar y quemar, pero en realidad todo eso es ilegal.
y seríamos acusados de piratas por hacer eso,
porque esta música ha sido privatizada.
Ahora es propiedad, buena parte de ella, de las grandes industrias.
Así que, realmente, la clave aquí es que no podemos permitir que esto suceda.
No podemos dejar que suceda aquí lo que pasó con Napster.
Entonces, lo que tenemos que hacer es hacerlo bien desde el principio,
y lo que tenemos que hacer
es encontrar un marco de propiedad intelectual que haga seguro compartir,
y hacerlo fácilmente comprensible,
y la inspiración aquí es tomada del software de código abierto,
cosas como Linux y la GPL.
Y las ideas, las licencias Creative Commons.
¿Cuántas personas han oído hablar de Creative Commons?
Si no lo han hecho, deben aprender acerca de ellas. Creativecommons.org.
En la parte inferior de cada pieza de material en Connexions
y en muchos otros proyectos, pueden encontrar este logotipo.
Hacer clic en ese logotipo los lleva a un documento con total sentido,
legible por humanos,
una escritura que les dice exactamente lo que pueden hacer con este contenido.
De hecho, usted es libre para compartirlo, para hacer todas estas cosas,
para copiarlo, para cambiarlo, incluso para hacer uso comercial de él
siempre y cuando atribuya el trabajo a su autor.
Porque en las publicaciones académicas,
y gran parte de las publicaciones educativas,
en realidad es por esta idea de compartir el conocimiento, por eso, y por tener impacto,
es por eso que la gente escribe, no necesariamente para hacer dólares.
No estamos hablando de Harry Potter.
Estamos en el extremo de la larga cola aquí.
Detrás de esto está el código legal,
construido de una manera muy cuidadosa,
y Creative Commons está despegando.
Hay más de 43 millones de cosas por ahí,
licenciadas bajo una licencia Creative Commons.
No sólo texto sino música, imágenes, video
y hay en realidad una enorme aceptación
del número de personas que están licenciando música
para que sea libre para las personas que hacen todo esto de re-muestrear,
copiar, mezclar, quemar y compartir.
Así que me gustaría concluir con tan sólo unos últimos puntos.
Hemos creado esta idea de un patrimonio común. La gente la está usando.
Recibimos más de 500.000 visitantes únicos por mes, sólo nuestro sitio en particular.
OpenCourseWare de MIT, que es otro gran sitio de contenido abierto,
recibe un número similar de accesos pero ¿cómo protegemos esto?
¿Cómo podemos protegerlo en el futuro?
y la primera cosa que la gente está pensando es, probablemente, el control de calidad.
Porque estamos diciendo que cualquiera puede contribuir con cosas
a este patrimonio común. Cualquiera puede aportar cualquier cosa,
de modo que esto podría ser un problema.
Entonces no pasó mucho tiempo,
para que la gente comenzara a contribuir, por ejemplo, con materiales sobre lencería,
que en realidad es un muy buen módulo.
El único problema es que es plagiado,
de una importante revista feminista francesa
y cuando van al supuesto sitio web del curso,
apunta a un sitio web de venta de ropa interior, ¿de acuerdo?
Así que este es un problema,
por lo que claramente necesitamos algún tipo de idea de control de calidad
y es aquí en donde aparece la idea de la revisión y la revisión por pares.
Ok, usted viene a TED. ¿Por qué viene a TED?
Porque Chris y su equipo han garantizado
que las cosas son de muy, muy alta calidad,
así que necesitamos ser capaces de hacer lo mismo.
Y tenemos que ser capaces de diseñar estructuras
y lo que estamos haciendo es diseñando software social
para permitir a cualquier persona construir su propio proceso de revisión de pares
y llamamos a estas cosas lentes
y básicamente lo que permiten a cualquier persona
es desarrollar su propio proceso de revisión de pares,
a fin de que puedan centrarse en el contenido en el repositorio
que piensan que es realmente importante
y se puede pensar en TED como un lente potencial.
Así que quisiera terminar diciendo,
que ustedes puede ver esto como un llamado a la acción.
Connexions y el contenido abierto se tratan de compartir conocimiento.
Todos ustedes aquí están tremendamente impregnados
con enormes cantidades de conocimiento
y lo que me gustaría hacer es invitar a todos y cada uno de ustedes
a contribuir a este proyecto y otros proyectos de su tipo,
porque creo que juntos podemos cambiar verdaderamente el panorama
de la educación y las publicaciones educativas.
Entonces, muchas gracias.